i am not a kid person
like i
it's just not in me i think as a woman
it's either in your isn't you either
have that maternal feeling or you don't
and i've never had that feeling
[Music]
hey guys i'm jessie nelson and this is
my glamour unfiltered interview
two years ago i told glamour that i was
in a place where i never thought i'd be
happy again and now i'm sitting here and
i can generally say handle my heart that
i am
the happiest i've ever been in a long
time and i think
the main reason for that is because i've
taken control over my life
and
[Music]
i've looked after myself i think we
don't look after ourselves enough in
life like some people think it's selfish
to
you know look after yourself and take
control of your life i think it's so
important to do that because as cheesy
as it sounds you only live once
i think the girls knew that i was
struggling for a long time like it
wasn't a secret
i'd been quite open with how i'd been
feeling over the last few years and it
was kind of yeah towards last year that
it got really really bad for me and um
i just think yeah they just knew that
like it was just time for me to like
take a minute to like just deal with
what i was going through and
just focus on myself and look after
myself and
it's always going to feel weird for me
like
not not speaking to the girls because
obviously you know we were in a band
together for 10 years like i said we all
we were like sisters like my right arm
and so to like have that 24 7 in my life
to then just have them not there at all
is a very very
weird strange feeling but it's just one
of them things like things happen in
life but you know i still love them to
pieces and they've got their little
babies now and they're starting their
own families and it's a really exciting
time for them all individually so
yeah it's just just one of them things i
think is going to take time
i would say i'm a solid 10.
don't get me wrong i'll have days when i
might wake up and something should
happen and i might be a nine but
genuinely i would say i'm a solid 10.
i personally think that me being a solo
artist is better for my mental health
because
i
am not being compared to my bandmates
every single day i feel like until
you've experienced the trauma that i've
experienced like with people 24 7 like
slating how you look physically
it puts you in a place where you lose
all confidence and
so to then have to do video shoots and
be around three beautiful girls who are
like half the size of you and constantly
compare yourselves in whilst having the
whole world also compare you it was a
lot to take on so when i'd come to music
videos when i come to photo shoots i
would
constantly compare myself i'd be like oh
god i don't look as skinny as them or i
don't look as pretty as them or i don't
look how i how i should look in this
outfit how they do and it's it was a lot
of pressure that i put on myself for 10
years and now i don't have that i'm just
i'm just me and i'm being able to be
myself for the first time ever and it
just it feels very liberating and i feel
like a massive weight has been lifted
off my shoulders there's only one me and
i think when we start to realize that
our own power when we start to realize
that god there's one me in the world
there's no other me like that's amazing
like there's no there's no one in the
world like you and if we all realize
that i think we'd all be really bloody
confident
ten years ago i had despised myself i
couldn't even look at myself in the
mirror i just yeah my confidence was the
lowest it could ever be i've never
walked in studio and been genuinely
excited to try on the clothes which is
how a girl should feel when they walk
into a studio and have a rack of clothes
in front of them and be like oh because
that's every girl's dream to be able to
like try on different clothes and wear
whatever they want but for me it was
like panic and anxiety just 24 7. and i
remember one of my first experiences
of a photo shoot of being in little mix
i think the stylist had got the wrong
size and it was like a size eight and
i'm a size 12
and so i remember putting on the clothes
and they didn't fit me and i remember
thinking oh my god i'm so fat i can't
fit into the clothes and i wasn't aware
that it was because she'd got the wrong
size so walking into a studio now
genuinely like i feel excited i feel
excited to see what clothes are on the
rail because i know that they're
clothes that i want to wear the clothes
that i feel comfortable in they're just
me all over i did a video shoot the
other day
and i wore a crop top i've never i would
never wear a crop top in a video ever
and
i had a few little rolls when i was
moving but i didn't care like i didn't
look at him think oh my god no i don't
like before i would have been like
someone give me a t-shirt i don't want
to wear a belly top with us i just
didn't care and i think that's because
i've just genuinely learnt to like
accept my body and just i mean like
there's only one me
[Music]
one million percent i was using makeup
and hair to like mask
who i genuinely was because obviously
when i was on x factor i got ridiculed i
got slated for like my face and my
weight and how i looked and so i did
everything i could
to not be
that girl that was on x factor i tried
to go on ridiculous diets to lose weight
i tried to i changed my hair all the
time i
you know
got lip fillers i i did everything i
could to to be
what i thought the public
wanted me to look like and then i
realized
slowly and like when i was changing
which is really sad like when i did lose
weight and when i
you know
my appearance did start to change that
then that's when people started to
accept me and i was like wow this is
this is really sad
for like the majority of my
time in little mix i just used to wear
corsets all the time and i'd make my
stylist put me in the most ridiculous
things to make myself skinnier because i
just so badly wanted to look like jade
perry and leanne i just wanted to be as
tiny as them so i'd make them put me in
these courses and for half the time
oh of me working i just couldn't breathe
and i just and i genuinely have like
bruises because i'd been pulled in so
much from this course here and now
like now i we're tr i literally live in
track suits and trainers the majority of
you know my time and i i just feel so
much more comfortable and confident and
that's how i know that i'm getting there
with my confidence because i would never
have done that like two years ago
i would say that i'm definitely not at
that stage yet i'd be up i'd be if i was
like oh i'd happily see you with no
makeup and no hair extensions because
for me like i'm still in a work in
progress with my confidence i'm
definitely getting there one million
percent
2013 i genuinely genuinely thought i am
never ever going to feel happy again
like i just didn't every day i would
wake up and i think
this is this is how this is me now like
this is how i feel and i can't change
that there is nothing i can do to pull
myself out of this and you honestly feel
like you're never ever going to move
past that and that's what gets you into
that state of thinking well why am i
even here like what is the point
but
if you can push through that and push
past it
like you're stronger than you even know
like that's what i've realized about
myself that i
i think i'm gonna be upset but like i
that i can't actually believe how how
strong i am and like when i look back at
like stuff that i never thought i'd get
from like
no like i did that like i'll push i push
past that and there's nothing i feel
that i can't do now like i've got
through that awful stage of my life like
there's nothing you could put in front
of me now that i feel like i couldn't do
and i feel really proud of myself
no one has actually ever come up to me
and said sorry for the things that
they've said but you know what i'll just
think well you're just a coward and that
just explains
that just says to me who you are as a
person
i just genuinely felt back then not
everyone hated me but now like
when i genuinely think about it
no one who is genuinely happy in their
life feels the need to go around being
negative towards other people because
when you're a happy person
you just
ooze that energy
one thing that i
personally feel works for me is just
being around my friends and family as
much as possible and genuinely like
taking the time to do the things that i
love dancing as well is a big therapy
for me
me and my sister used to be so close
when we were younger like before i was
on x factor and then when i got an x
factor i feel like my mum and my sister
felt like they lost me
and
not long ago literally it was about
three weeks ago i was um in antigua and
my sister flew out there with me and we
spent the whole time together and she
when she left she really cried and she
went home to my mom and she said it's
honestly the best holiday i've had
because i felt like i had like my little
sister back
[Music]
my single is going to be out very soon
and i'm i'm not i mean i may sound like
i'm blowing my own trumpet but i'm gonna
it's amazing and i'm really proud of it
and um i wrote it when i was going
through a breakup it's very honest i
feel like it's very [ __ ] in your
face i feel like some people are gonna
be hate it or some people gonna love it
but you know what i love that i would
rather it be a love hate situation then
it'd be in the middle and be like yeah
it's all right she could
feel like she could have pushed it a bit
more
um
yeah i'm just so proud of it and i'm so
excited for the world to hear it
someone said to me do you think it's
because of the way he was brought up
like obviously
my dad wasn't the best role model i
never had a dad around he was always in
and out of prison
um so were my brothers
and i don't know if it's because of the
way i've been brought up
or
i don't know what it is but like i've
tried nice boys and it just
it doesn't work out they just become my
friends and i get really bored i had a
bad boy and i bloody hated it i thought
that was what i wanted i wanted to be
kept on my toes and then when i had it
it was awful and i thought god i'd love
to just go back to someone who treats me
like a princess now so i think what i
need now is like a mixture of both and
if i could find that then i think
i'd be on to a winner
i'm not gonna lie i love love i meet
someone if i like them i instantly fall
in love and then about six months later
i realized it wasn't love it was just
infatuation but this time in my 30s i
just want to be all about me i want to
love me there's so many times i was in
relationships and i'd wake up and like
i'd have had an argument with my
boyfriend the night before and then it
affects everything the next day when you
go to work and i'd be in the worst mood
ever heartbreak is the worst thing you
can go through and i right now i ain't
got time for that
i've been brought up by my mum
all by herself
she had four kids and she brought us all
up on her own and i've never really felt
like
you know i have to be married i have to
have kids because i've seen my mum do it
all on her own and she's the best best
mum in the world like she's wonder woman
to me
i am not a kid person
like i
it's just not in me i think as a woman
it's either in your isn't you either
have that maternal feeling or you don't
and i've never had that feeling like i
can appreciate that a baby is cute but
like i don't i don't get around babies
and be like oh
let me hold him
that's just not in me that's not me at
all like i've got a nephew and he's the
cutest thing ever but after 10 minutes
he drives me nuts
so yeah there'll be no kids for me it's
the only thing i think i'm going to
struggle with finding a man that doesn't
want kids maybe i'm gonna have to find a
man that's like
already as a kid and i'll just be a
stepmom
i would like to have a sellout tour
sell out jesse nelson tour i would like
to have had a successful album
um i would like to have gone to the met
gala
there's quite a few people that i would
love to collaborate with one of them
being dojika
i mean i feel proud of myself now like
honestly this is i feel so proud of
myself but i'd like to look back and
think
you did well girl you did it